how badly do not want people to buy this
very badly I tell you well I don't know
of any other mob guy that ever did
anything like this this belongs on the
dark web for sure it is President's Day
2020 and I am all alone here at the
office because I've decided to return to
the dark web yay I made a couple of
videos now about the dark web and those
experiences were fairly fruitful okay
but I also recently made a series of
videos for the former mafia member named
Michael Franzese Michael and I have
since become fairly close friends he is
one of my two favorite Michaels on my
phone and actually got to thinking and I
got genuinely curious because in many
ways Michael represents an old way of
crime so I wanted to bring him in to
look at the dark webbing game his
thoughts as to how technology has shaped
crime and how criminal activity can be
conducted today how are you good to see
you my good to see good to see you back
you look great
very quickly Michael before we start
filming the video we need just a few
cool shots of you we coming out of the
car for your intro to the concert we
want the audience to kind of know you
know who you are
my name is Michael Franzese I am a
former soldier and capo regime in the
Colombo crime family in New York and
today I'm here to set foot into the very
dangerous world of the dark web look at
the camera that's perfect
cut hey there you are there there that's
what we like so Michael what do you know
about the dark web nothing I don't know
anything about it the dark web can only
be accessed through special routing
software or browsers these browsers for
example I want to clarify they're not
necessarily bad anyone can access them
it's not illegal to have them what
happens with these browsers they can't
be tracked so in other words as a
mobster I'd be using the dark web and
not anything on top of that exactly
gotcha so what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to show you some of the marketplaces on
the dark web and get your thoughts okay
so in other words you can buy a
fraudulent Visa Mastercard or Amex you
can buy these home online yeah wow it's
amazing to me that people would do
business online like this really and you
can buy a PayPal account with a four
thousand dollar balance what's the price
on that fifty four dollars so four fifty
four dollars you can buy a PayPal
account that has four thousand dollars
in it that's why that's what it says
right there yeah I'll tell you what we
wanted this sophisticated my day and
when I was indicted for racketeering
you know the underlying acts were fraud
and one of the fraudulent acts was
credit card for it you know credit card
fraud has been around forever it was a
thing that the mob used to get involved
in we used to get credit card we printed
him up at times and and all the times we
just got him from other places so
familiar with that again you know we'd
never think it would be online let's say
this the dark web existed back in your
day and you were able to have the option
of performing or your associate
performing credit card fraud online
would you still go with the methods you
used back in the day or would you go
online you know I think part of the
reason my former associates the mob got
in trouble because we didn't keep up
with technology you know there was one
time they had bugs in the parking meters
we used to go talk by the parking meters
and they had bugged the meters one of
the reasons so many guys got in trouble
we never kept up with technology we
didn't and government was way ahead of
us on it so you know having that my head
I'd be afraid to use any of this and
leave that kind of a trail however no
doubt guys on the street would be using
this if this was a you know an avenue
for them to commit their activity they
would do it no doubt about it I probably
get caught at some point so this is
drugs now so give me your thoughts on
this so they're selling xanax
at feta mines so this is basically a
drug dealers paradise on here
oxycodone oh gosh that stuff I'm telling
you I don't wash you know I had
daughters and went to college and I know
a dural was big back tennis mat fact I
was writing a book and I was on a
deadline and had to hand it in and my
daughter is trying to give me an
adderall she said dad you know this will
keep you awake I'll be honest - sleep
for three days
oh Jesus because I never took a drug in
my life she gave me that I said how do
you kids do this did you face the book I
finished the book oh yeah I could read
another book which book with it I wish
I'll make you an offer you couldn't
refuse yeah available now yes of course
I got a ask though in The Godfather for
example hmm you know one of the plot
points was at the Corleone's they kind
of refused to get into the drug business
right when you were with the Colombo
crime family
was everything that you guys didn't want
to touch yeah a couple of things the
night I got straightened out we would
tall that night we deal with drugs we
die no drugs
as a matter of fact I had a dear friend
of mine his name was Tony Jaa he was a
made guy who was a soldier unto me he
got arrested for drugs
along with the boss's son and he came to
me and he said Mike I'm in trouble
he said we sold drugs to an undercover
cop and I said them don't worry about it
I'm gonna straighten out
he was an old-time guy he was so scared
okay that he was gonna get walked into a
room and get killed because he got
involved in drugs he went into a phone
booth blew his brains out killed himself
because he said I don't want anybody to
walk me into a room I'd rather do it
myself
that's the fear of us selling drugs at
the time so it was off limits
so whenever you see these stories I know
there's been movies out there and you
know where mob guys were involved
heavily in drugs not true mr. silly ins
from the Mafia there were big drug
dealers they were heroin dealers but we
didn't get involved we weren't allowed
to get involved I never sold a drug and
never took a drug I'm all life until
that Rob well yeah yeah I'll be honest
with you too during my time in that life
I don't remember anybody being involved
in prostitution never and the other
thing that that I just drives me crazy
when I hear about it you know when
they're kidnapping these kids and
selling them
yes sex trafficking if any of our guys
would have gotten involved in that in
any way they would have got killed when
I hear about it today I can't believe
how widespread it is just horrible stuff
unfortunately the dark web is a place
where a lot of let's say video content
of such really acts can be found and
sold Wow a while ago I went on the dark
web before and I've actually purchased
some things off of it so we paid money
for a set of dark web links so you could
go further into the dark web but I just
want to show you some of the stuff that
these links can lead to when I can go to
visiting them but some of them are quite
shocking you see what that says right
there next to that pedo videos yeah
beautiful videos god now disgusting
that's just horrible horrible but you
got to be sick I mean there's there's no
other explanation for that you know Ari
I gotta be honest with you me we did
some rough things in my time in that
life but some of the things that I'm
hearing now I mean I just can't believe
it you know all of these murders in
these these kids and these gangs they
have no regard or respect for human life
at all in our life I'm not gonna say
violence wasn't a part of it it
absolutely was I'm not gonna say guys
didn't get killed they did no doubt but
we were told straight out when you come
into that life we have certain rules
that you have to follow and if you don't
follow it you could pay for it with your
life and your best friend might be
called upon to take care of that you
might be called into a room one night by
your best friend you don't walk out
again that's one of the horrors of that
life but murder was taken very very
seriously it wasn't random
it had to be approved by the boss only
the boss can approve a murder and there
was a lot of discussion about I mean was
taken very seriously weren't random
killers I don't know where these people
come from man but it's this is this
that's that's really a dark side of the
internet the dark web obviously is a
place where you can find the worst of
things but I will say it's also a place
where people can find safety and kind of
the privacy a lot of whistleblowers use
it as a way of spreading documents some
people you're on Facebook on it cuz they
still want to be tracked
I believe the New York Times has its own
dark web site too you can find the worst
of the worst but you can find some good
too and so what I want to do with you is
actually going to sell something on the
dark web No okay the dark web is a place
where some things get sold that people
don't want to have sold mm-hmm so I want
to sell something that would potentially
you know might be a little
incriminating or embarrassing for the
both of us mm-hmm and I'm just wondering
do you have any guilty pleasure songs oh
god I I mean it's not gonna sound right
because you know my chill form a mob guy
and all that but you know I'm really
into musicals that's that's my favorite
kind of movie oh my god yeah Sound of
Music
till today that's my favorite movie of
all time I mean to sound of every song
in there I love and I'm singing around
my house I sing with my kids they all
think I'm out of my mind and crazy so
one might say it would be quite
embarrassing should a former mafioso be
singing a sound of music I think so yes
I think so this is our prop house we're
just gonna go to the costume section
about 25 some Austrian looking hats I
will be Maria do I really need to wear
this if my wife was sure I couldn't do
this when it goes alive let me know
because I'm gonna disappear for the day
if you use it me up Michael white kids
are gonna think I lost my mind are we
saying anything we just what's the thing
okay
all right Captain Von Trapp yes sir my
Maria oh okay Maria Anna won Michael and
I have a video that we really don't want
anyone to find that's for sure and so we
would like to go through the process of
listing it on the dark web so in case
someone does really want to put in the
effort to purchase it they can so you
spent the weekend kind of already
getting yourself established as a vendor
yeah so the first biggest hurdle to get
around is you need to put a bond down
because it'll like filter out a lot of
the scammers if you're putting $500 down
upfront it's gonna stop a lot of people
from just jumping on listing fake drugs
getting money and then dipping out you
have to pay 500 dollars you have to pay
$500
the company would owe me money
they don't want to pay for it then you
owe me money on the company card so
there's a vetting process to the basic
stuff is like making sure that you're
safe you're not scamming why not you
have you your crypto wallet verified you
have your PGP key verified like some
semblance of your identification
verified so you at least like know a
little bit about use and they know that
you are just essentially an honest
vendor coming on when obviously Michael
and I are very honest vendors obviously
we just have one innocent video we'd
like to put a for sale on the account so
how do we list it do we want to put a
title on here so people can find it yeah
let me get really grabby leaked video it
all caps ex mafia kingpin and Asian man
oh and handsome Asian man handsome the
heads of ex mafia kingpin and handsome
Asian man caught singing Broadway
musical I put on brackets
very rare that's pretty good time
waiting Michael that works yeah price
how much do these things usually go for
you would say this is a first you tell
me what this is worth to you I'll tell
you well I don't know of any other mob
guy that ever did anything like this so
there's got to be a pretty heavy price
on this big price tag how badly do not
want people to buy this very badly deep
dark secret this belongs on the dark web
for sure tell me what you've wanted for
in US Dollars and will posted for sale
with Manero which is a cryptocurrency
it's a privacy coin oh man five hundred
bucks three bucks all right that's just
for five hundred bucks
all right 6.07 Manero a feeling the FBI
will try to buy this and that that's it
my old reputation goes down the sewer
but but in a good way I guess people who
really knew I left that life behind now
think about selling digital goods like
this if we could have multiple people
buying it if we felt like selling more
than one of these because some more than
one but we could just never know we
might make some money off of this and if
we don't deliver then we get a bad
review we don't want a bad review we
don't want a bad review and you know
what this shows me quite honestly is
that you know mob guys former mob guys
it was a human side to us too we don't
show it all the time on the street but
you know this is all a good fun
Michael wanted to do the honors it hit
that list right here yeah just go ahead
and click it there it is where the odds
that we actually sell this thing
probably not very high I'm sorry Michael
that's okay well no that's good that's
good the only one that's gonna buy this
is me so that nobody else buys it that's
it so I guess we just wait Jake thank
you so much of course you are you're an
expert I guess keep us posted on how
things go you always say I'm an expert
I'm just like the only person that this
company that knows anything about it I'm
very impressed I gotta be honest with
you I would hire you back then well if
you got any references yeah I do
Michael thank you again for coming
dark web your final thoughts on that
just fascinating you know it's a whole
new I mean I see it from a criminal
standpoint I see from a legit it's just
a whole new area that I was never aware
of and now we have something listed on
there together all right wish me how it
goes all right man bye sir bye-bye take
care take care that's my friend
[Music]